that's what this book is really about
the book is about me fathers and
daughters very good best thing I've ever
written I'm gonna get this sold by lunch
mothers and daughters has won every
major literary award JB you're the real
Kate Davis your father changed my life
that's my girl
how close is the book to what actually
happened
any minute
those seizures are a sign of something
far more serious and if you don't at
least try treatment you will end up with
a much worse condition I can't do you
have a daughter Teresa it's exactly why
you need to I have to go away I love you
Katie please do it
so what would you do if you met a man
that you actually did like but all
that's behind you now
Lucy Carter she hasn't spoken a word
since her mother's funeral
I'm gonna be here to help you I promise
you that
Katie I don't know how to do this
you know no one that loves you is going
to leave you you're the best thing that
ever happened to me
I'm gonna stay with you
no matter how hard things get
we can never give up
you